[Music]
foreign you are watching The Press
preview of first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive it's time to
see what's making the headlines with the
columnist Carol Malone and the editor of
The Courier in Dundee David Clegg
they'll be with us from now up until
right just before midnight so let's see
see what's on some of those front pages
for you now with the I says Deputy Prime
Minister Dominic Raab is refusing to
resign over allegations of bullying
which he's always denied
the guardian describes Mr Rob as
fighting for his political life
while the time says he's standing firm
while the Prime Minister considers the
report into the bullying claims
the mirror reports that Thomas Cashman
the man who's convicted of murdering
nine-year-old Olivia Pratt Corbell is to
appeal his 42-year jail sentence
the Metro has news of the SpaceX rocket
launch which didn't go entirely to plan
referring to the company's boss they say
Elon we have a problem
the mail reports unelected members of
the House of Lords are planning to block
the government's new bill to stop judges
halting migrant deportations
the express says MPS want to know why
the BBC reportedly ignored their call to
protect women's rights in its coverage
of transgender issues
the financial times carries quotes from
the head of the U.S federal reserve on
the importance of trying to maintain
economic links with China
the sun leads with the funeral today of
Television presenter and dog lover Paul
O'Grady
and the style of does almost exactly the
same
and reminder that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us and we are joined tonight by
Carol Malone and David Clegg welcome to
both of you let's start with the
guardian and the the story that Carrie
well it is carrying through the night we
thought we might have some sort of a
resolution on it today but this is
Dominic Robb's fight for his political
lie Carol
Dominic Robb has seen the report and he
always said that if if the report
you know upheld the charges of bullying
he would resign now he hasn't resigned
so that says something to me he's he's
saying he doesn't believe that those
charges are being upheld and the the
report itself does not say he's broken
the ministerial code you know I almost
been suspicious of this inquiry and you
know we can't be throwing ministers to
the wolves on the say-so of civil
servants who actually hate the Tories
and who are very partisan and and I
think you know these people think they
run the country and many of them I've
been saying today that they'll resign uh
if Rob doesn't reside or doesn't get
fired well let them resign you know if
the report doesn't say he is guilty of
bullying well then why why on Earth
would he resign
do you think that they've they've not um
had any case to to bring to Mr Rob then
is that what you're saying that their
their claims are serious
what we know and what what has been put
in the public domain is claims from
Anonymous civil servants people are
white or former former ministers in
Whitehall anonymously saying what a
bullying was now let me tell you just
some of the claims one former um
minister so one form of civil servants
in a civil serpent said called him a
monster and this was his explanation of
how Rob was the monster he said
um I I saw him seething and hard staring
at you cold Fury that is it well is that
Bullock I don't think it is and one of
the claims that was made was that he
threw Tomatoes at a at someone in a
meeting now when you drill down into
that story it was the Metro around that
so when you drill down into that he
didn't throw them with anybody he took
them out of his salad and thrown them
onto a piece of paper on the table so
everything that I'd heard and all these
civil servants who are briefing which is
you know they're not supposed to do that
they're all briefing and honestly if I
could see something from someone who
went on the record and said this is what
he did I might believe it but Anonymous
claims I don't believe the only person
who's ever gone on the record is Gina
Miller and she said um that he bullied
her her thing was she said she says he
bullied and demeaned me and apparently
what he's what he said to her was that
she was naive well I didn't call that
bullying either you know a lot of
ministers are sticking her for Robin
saying you know he's a man who has
exacting standards you know when he when
he won something done he wants it done
and the way he says and if people aren't
doing their job properly he has a right
to be angry and he has a right to say so
so I I would like to know what is in
this report and that's for labor and the
lib Dems accusing
um accusing Rishi of dithering he's not
dithering the report only came out this
afternoon and he's gone now he's got to
sleep on it it's quite the right thing
and the rational thing to do David your
view um because it has been a long time
in coming it's five five months this
inquiry has been going on and we were
expecting some sort of decision from the
Prime Minister today is he dithering
he's certainly taken his time and his
motivation for that worries me I think I
disagree with quite a lot of what Carol
said there and I think we should be
careful to be accurate that what the the
report is not making it not drawing a
conclusion on Weller Dominic grad Brook
the ministerial code which said there
should be which says there should be
Zero Tolerance of bullying that's a
that's a problem with the process I
think rather than the a suggestion that
this report is by its nature vindicating
and it's deliberately not drawing a
conclusion it's Gathering the facts and
then presenting them to the Prime
Minister who is the person who is then
got to decide whether whether the
ministerial code has been broken and I
don't know whether Domino grab was
bullying civil servants any more than
Carol does what I do know is that um I I
wrote a book about Alex salmond and his
dealings with the Civil Service uh which
left something to be desired quite often
and what what I find when I spoke to a
lot of civil servants uh are around that
was that these are very robust people
they are used to behavior years that and
normal workplaces wouldn't be acceptable
it takes quite a lot to uh for them to
be concerned about the behavior they're
willing to put up with quite a bit
realizing that they're working in a high
pressured extreme high functioning
environment so whenever civil servants
come forward and make claims like this I
think they should be taken seriously and
they are in a position that it's
actually there's less protection for
them sometimes than there isn't in other
occupations the fact that the prime
minister is then the person who
adjudicates on Weller someone who is a
political Ally and colleague of his uh
well are their standards have fallen
short I think that is actually a
structural problem of the system which
could do with being looked at it feels
to me like there needs to be some
independent verification or scrutiny on
Weller the the ministerial code has been
broken and it shouldn't just be the
facts or Gallery put in a report and
then the Prime Minister can sleep on it
and decide that because we know that
there is a lot especially with the
problems that Rishi sunak has and
keeping the conservative party together
there's a lot of speculation in the
press that part of that his hesitation
here is that uh he feels like he's
there's a there's after a period of you
know pretty intense Civil War amongst
the conservative party that there's a an
uneasy pieces being brokered in some way
and he's he's reluctant to get back into
more problems so I think we need to be
very careful about
um pre-judging what went on here but I
think what we should uh be careful about
is that the process is followed properly
and that there is robust scrutiny of
this so what I would like to see is the
report published so that we can all take
a look at exactly what Adam thuli Casey
has what has has fined out and what his
report contains to see the information
that Rishi sunak is making that decision
on and then and then we can come to some
kind of conclusion and whether we agree
with them I what I would say is that if
this is a report that says there's
nothing to see here there's no problem
then why is it taking him so long to to
say that publicly Carol is right that
Dominic grab said the defeat was found
that he had been bullying people that he
would resign he has not resigned so it's
clear that he is of the review that the
report is not career ending for him and
he can retain his position and I guess
the question that we're waiting for the
answer to Is does Rishi soon Act take
the same view and say so yes that is the
issue just to say to bring us to the eye
and that point on on the fact that
they're they're reporting that uh
Dominic Robb is refusing to resign
um the report the prime minister is
reading through this evening we presume
through through the night but the fact
that there hasn't been a clear-cut
decision suggests that it is more nuance
and there perhaps is is more to the
report that that needs to be um looked
at
but yes and I think that's it and I
think David just said before you know
the person has to be followed properly
of course it does that's why the prime
minister is reading this report again
and very closely overnight is not going
to rush to a decision you know he wants
dominate Rob to state government of
course he does he's an ally of his but
you know what David has just said before
he said you know these people are robust
people and they don't you know they're
not they're not easily offended or upset
I mean that's all very well what
what Civil Service there is blatantly
partisan a civil service that hates the
Tories and has shown its hatred of the
Tories in in all sorts of ways what
evidence are you
basingly they're robust people it's not
robust if someone says to someone hard
stares at you and you think that's
bullying this is a guy who wants a job
done and of people in his Department
aren't doing it properly he's all right
just to tell them that can you just
answer that that point that David raised
on what evidence are you basing the fact
that Civil Service the Civil Service
hate the Tories it hit the tourism
because the Civil Service itself in
impartiality
oh let's talk about Sue gray then should
we they really Pride themselves on
impartiality but the queen you know what
they have done they try to thwart
processes to do with brexit and all the
things that they disagree with to do
with immigration let David you read the
premise as well as I do you know what's
been happening so don't pretend
and I have not under the conclusion at
all the Civil Service here at the Tories
and that this is a plot
so I'm just wondering why you have
what the Civil Service want to thwart
the government at almost every turn and
this will be you know they are saying
today if Rishi doesn't soon if Rishi
doesn't sack Rob lots of them are going
to reside I mean it's not the den to say
what the prime ministers do the process
says the Prime Minister has the final
word it's not for them to try and push
his hand and say you know if you don't
we're going to resign or let them resign
let's move on to the let's move on to
the the metro and something that David
mentioned before and it's the
decision-making process now I'm not sure
whether we will actually get to see
um the report but but that's that is
going to be quite crucial isn't it on
what his base is the decision my
understanding is they've made a pledge
that we will see it I don't understand
why we haven't seen it already why it's
a secret up until Russia's decided what
he thinks of it that seems a bit strange
to me I I do think that this and and
without judging this particular
circumstance to this particular case or
what the outcome of it is it does seem
to me that it does show again that this
process is flawed that the ultimate
adjudicator of Weller uh Rishi sunax uh
ministers have been bullying the Civil
Service Israel
I don't like that and it's not just
about this government has been the
process uh well certainly it's the
existing process regardless of political
persuasion and it's the same process
largely that's followed in Scotland as
well so it's not a party political point
but it seems to me that there's
something unfair about it and it could
do with being looked up
you did see it before the Prime Minister
has seen it looked at it instead of
surely you're not suggesting we should
it should be made I'm not I'm certainly
not saying that the public should see it
before the Prime Minister but at the
same time
I just wanted to find out whether you
think that these claims of bullying by
the civil servants whether they
shouldn't be investigated at all
no of course
the citigated of course they should but
like I said before when everything
everything variously newspapers around
the story they didn't name a single
source for these stories now when I say
unnamed sources on a story I don't
necessarily believe that story to be
true if you have the courage of your
conventions and if dominant wrong
bullied you why not say so instead of
briefing sometimes there's a good reason
to remain anonymous though if you you
fear reprisals but on that note we will
we will leave it there Carol let's take
a look at the Metro and the big SpaceX
problem uh well the headline says Elon
we have a problem uh what did you make
of the launch
um David did you see it
I I watched some of it back uh
afterwards I think I think there's
something quite interesting about it in
that if you're looking at that Metro
front page you would think that this has
been a disaster uh and the phrase a
rapid unscheduled disassembly which is
how they described it uh certainly
suggests that there is a problem but but
actually uh Elon Musk uh and SpaceX that
their their perspective on this is that
they were doing this to learn that they
they have learned a lot from it and they
believe they're still on Target and
having read around it a bit this evening
it does seem that the most of the
experts seem to be saying that this
actually has been successful in doing
what they were trying to do that they
understood that they were going to lose
this big this this vessel and that uh
there could be problems and that they
still are on schedule to make big
strides in space exploration from this I
think given it's Elon Musk uh given his
recent uh public uh Persona that there's
uh perhaps a reluctance uh from the
media to uh give him credit where it's
due and that they're they're hoping for
a disaster especially because today uh
he's taking their blue ticks away from
all the journalists on Twitter yeah so
perhaps there's there's some there's
something there in his in their desire
to put him down but I I am certainly no
rocket scientist uh which that is is
pretty obvious but it does seem from
Reading around some of the people who
are rocket scientists and understand the
the science behind this that it is
actually quite an impressive feat and it
does still look like this Starship uh is
on course ultimately to to revolutionize
space travel yeah certainly those in the
know are saying that it is a positive
and and um SpaceX was saying just to get
off the launching pad would would have
been a success cow really yeah but there
was
it was
it was just so orbit the earth once
before it crashed into the Pacific it
didn't get Mexico from Texas correct but
did you see them cheering when when it
actually exploded I did but I did and I
couldn't quite understand when they were
cracking open the champagne and shouting
go Starship after the explosion I didn't
quite get that was a bit like David I
thought what's going on but I mean you
know musk will try and talk it up and
say this was a success but it was
supposed to orbit the earth once at
least and it didn't and it cracked it
cracked it exploded after I can't
remember how many seconds you guys have
been running the story all night but it
was it crashed after a few seconds but
it's but they said what I didn't realize
about this this rocket is it's the
biggest rocket ever built it's taller
than a 40-story building which is
incredible and it's got 17 million
pounds of thrust which is more than
those Saturn five rockets that used to
take the astronauts up into space and
and you know out to the moon so I just
think it's you know I don't believe what
Elon Musk said there's a huge success I
can't imagine we'll spend billions of
dollars in his defense others others
have have agreed um David I just wonder
if you can take us out on
um our goodbye to Paul O'Grady front
page of of the mirror his funeral today
yeah this is uh Paul O'Grady's funeral
today which was a very poignant but also
I think quite fittingly joyful occasion
as well uh it was full of dogs there was
a lot of animals there was a lot of love
it seemed very poignant uh and there's
some there's some actually lovely
coverage across the newspapers about it
today uh the son of perhaps done it most
powerfully in their tabloid fashion with
for the for the love of Paul and the
pictures of those dogs there but I think
he he was obviously someone who was
greatly loved greatly admired a fixture
of daytime TV for so long and we've run
out of time but David and Carol thank
you both for taking us through the paper